france 2 vous fera vivre à partir de
jeudi un autre événement considérable
festival de cannes
pourquoi partir de jeudi à partir de ce
soir bonsoir claudia cardinale nom soit
le guépard huit et demi il était une
fois dans l'ouest inutile de vous
présenter on vous invite ce soir parce
que vous êtes membre du jury
oui c'est la première fois c'est oui
absolument la première fois mais là me
retrouver à cannes c'est tellement de
souvenirs tellement de choses c'est
vraiment la fête du cinéma je suis tout
à fait heureuse d'être là alors claudia
cardinale quel est le rôle le plus
difficile à l'écran ou hors écran dans
la salle obscure avec tous ces crimes
que vous allez à là c'est plutôt
difficile hors écran je suis pas
tellement habitués juger un film non
maintenant je suis jugé donc c'est
doublement important mais enfin je
prends ça avec beaucoup de ce sera
formidable de voir tous ces films c'est
vraiment le festival la fête du cinéma
donc c'est formidable alors gilles jacob
en présentant la sélection à la
qualifier de cinéma commercial
intelligent quels seront vos goûts vos
critères sous la présidence de louis
malle le président du jury quels seront
vos critères pour apprécier ou ne pas
apprécier un film à il ya beaucoup de
facteurs c'est un peu difficile de vous
le dire
ça dépend des films ça dépend il ya des
films qui sont intéressants parce que
c'est un langage différent moderne
il ya des films qui sont intéressants
parce qu'il ya une très bonne
interprétation
enfin je crois que c'est très différent
mais vous allez privilégier l'émotion ou
la qualité esthétique du film vous même
la qualité la qualité oui alors ce 46e
festival édito dédié aux femmes avouent
ne pas comprendre parce que sans vous
sans les femmes n'y a pas de festival il
est toujours dédié aux femmes partout
des femmes pas seulement festival alors
pourquoi elle est il particulièrement
parce qu'il ya des femmes metteurs en
scène parce que il ya des ya des
actrices bien sûr des femmes metteurs en
scène y a des
il ya beaucoup plus d'hommes d'abord il
faut dire que les hommes sont plus
nombreux comme comme d'habitude oui mais
il n'y a jamais eu de palme d'or
féminine elle non c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
ouais c'est vrai et ça pourrait être le
cas cette année
ben on va essayer de se battre on parle
du film de jane campion
ouais il ya beaucoup de films
intéressants mais vous n'avez pas encore
vu ah non non vous allez commencer à
voir les films quand demain demain oui
vous n'avez pas quitté la salle ben on a
plusieurs films à voir par jour oui
alors pierre géraud donc qui est à
cannes pour préparer toute cette
opération pour nous pour france 2 me dis
que vous sortez d'un tournage tout à
fait original que qu'elle a oui j'ai
tourné avec blake edwards
le fils de la panthère rose qu'on a
tourné non un peu partout dans le monde
et il va sortir cet été et aussi rose
que les précédents
on va être assez délirant un sim
délirant je crois complètement rigolo ah
oui absolument
et quel rôle jouez vous je suis la maman
de roberto benigni qui est vraiment plus
fou que ça c'est pas possible donc on a
un peu une idée du sim
merci claudia cardinale pour ce ses
premières précisions ce premier
témoignage on va vous laisser regarder
tous les films on vous retrouvera à la
fin du festival évidemment pour avoir
votre appréciation est peu dire votre
vote
merci et bon festival merci arva